coach joins us the Continental Tire
Coaches Corner
Brian let me start with this we'll move
on quickly from this but this was a
heated discussion yesterday better
career Adrian Peterson Tiki Barber Wow
you know I faced that you're talking
about it in clear top three all-time in
yards per game with guys like Jim Brown
and Barry Sanders so it's hard not to go
with those numbers but I will say this
the overall impact Iggy Barger barber
was a 60 70 catch guy as well it was a
400 plus touch touch guy a couple times
in his in his career so and and not far
behind in terms of the sheer running
ability so if you throw in the total
aspect of impact on and having faced of
course we face in our Super Bowl in 2000
the fact that he could hurt you out of
the backfield as well yeah it's hard not
to go with Adrian Peterson is a pure
running back but it's a pure impact on
the team or if you had to choose one or
the other I'm not sure Ewing leaned
towards the Tiki Barber and there's
overall productivity all right now
today's question since you coached both
of them you can start your chain with
Ray Lewis or Randy Moss oh boy Wow
players I think Randy Moss is the most
dynamic talent when you've ever seen in
this league I don't know that he's the
best football player we've ever seen
overall but in terms of talent and the
ability to take over a game as Ray Lewis
again you're talking about the nature of
position and how much there's an inside
linebacker certainly what I could
dictate a game but Randy Moss change the
way we play in this league he would
change the way coverage had to do held
against him most freakish athlete we've
ever seen in the history of this game
you can start your defense with Ray
Lewis or ed Reed or your dear tested me
here you know ed was so dynamic out of
the in the back and your control waist
my set down corner but it's hard to
throw away from any impact safety like
an Ed Reed and Eric Berry an old Thomas
and the impact that they have on on a
team Ray Ray's the emotional tenant that
ray set and the tone that he said in
terms of against our defenses just we're
not going to run the ball
as much as I love the versatility of Ed
Reed it's hard not to lean towards our a
Louis in that regard yeah I would take
ed Reed I just think that he cleaned up
a lot whenever he made a big play it
became even bigger because he could take
it he could run it back I just I'm a
huge head read fan and I know you
coached both of them and both were great
people forget I'll throw in uh you know
back up what you're saying
unbelievable unbelievable and what he
could do in turn a lot of people don't
you know that's not the real folks when
you think about a tree but he was that
down that dynamic force on special teams
as well all right the week one reaction
the proper reaction a lot of it seems
overreacting because we don't know what
trends are going to take place but what
do you think is the proper reaction the
one reaction maybe or two reactions that
you think are going to play out the rest
of the year well that's that's what the
first week is about isn't it when you
look at a team like say Minnesota and
New Orleans was Minnesota really that
good is that something we should get
excited about or is that northern
defense really that bad if you look at
Kansas City and New England you don't
know anyone's going to bounce back and
they're playing New Orleans of what a
great defense for them to kind of
rebound against but as Kansas City if
indeed that explosiveness we know
they're efficient Alex Smith 22 24 O's
under 10 yards and they played great
defense we're used to that but if that
explosiveness
shows up on a consistent basis and that
changes the price of poker in the league
so we'll find out in the next year
during this next week whether that is
something you know can continue on we
saw some pretty good defenses being
played I can't think of a better game a
must-win all but in week two how about
that we knew and
you've got to have a bus win for
Cincinnati in Houston the loser of that
game was going to have a tough tough
slog going west away
he's Brian Billick NFL Network analyst
joining us Continental Tire coaches
corner do teams tank in the NFL field no
I don't believe that and I know we get
to the end of the season and people will
talk about this team or that player quit
I don't think that's the case now I will
say this to play in the National
Football League which is the most elite
level of this sport in order to compete
on a regular basis you have to be at
your steely-eyed best and if you're not
then you're not going to look good if
you're just that step less that let just
that little bit of less focus then then
you're gonna you're going to look back
you're going to look like you're
quitting I don't know that that's
necessarily someone quitting as much as
it is not playing up to the level that
this week demands it to play every
single week at what point with Andrew
Luck being out and continuing to be out
do you then say let's shut him down here
let me say your front office here you're
your owner Jim Irsay at what point do
you say it's not worth bringing him back
how many games how many weeks I think
looking at that football team I think
that decisions may have already been
made there not a very good football team
I don't think it has to be a matter of
what can I solve it you win or two here
and get to the point we're going back
maybe we could be pretty good you know
certainly if you if you run into that
second third fourth loss in a row what
would you bring him back for what is the
purpose other than to give the fans
something to cheer about and that's
going to be a tough one to do but why
would you expose Andrew Luck to that
depending upon the severity of the
injury and you know the question I
always have for my doctors could he hurt
this worse if they could and that's a
very easy decision if not than sure if
you want I'm sure he wants to come back
and play the Boyd Indianapolis just does
not look like a good football team with
or without Andrew Luck do you think the
Colin Kaepernick story continues each
week because of the bad quarterbacking
play that with him on the outside
looking in that this is just going to be
you know continuing dialogue about
should he be on a roster yeah absolutely
because particularly as teams seem to
struggle at the quarterback position now
not that he's going to make a difference
I think if he were to come back in the
league and I'm one of those
notwithstanding the things the
extracurricular things that people are
talking about it's certainly our factor
I think a lot of people don't sign
contact me because they're not sure
whether he can contribute to the team
that given the pool quarterback play
someone's going to end up signing him I
don't think he'll make a big prints with
them but someone will sign what would be
the one question as a coach that you
would want Colin Kaepernick answer is
this important to you is this you know
and we all have a lot of things going on
in our lives
that's not to diminish the things that
are important to him he's made public I
thought when when Baltimore was flirting
with the idea of bringing Kaepernick in
it was interesting to hear Joe Flacco I
did that Baltimore's preseason game
throws around a little bit more and when
that whole thing stirred up it was it
was interesting kind of subtle between
the lines with Joe Flacco said he said
you know we'd love to have Joe what
about that Colin Kaepernick here if he
wants to come in work hard and have fun
and I thought that was an interesting
way to phrase it basically saying if you
know will support you as a teammate but
some of that stuff you need to keep at
arm's length from here in the clubhouse
I thought that was interesting comment
and so you know I it's it's going to be
interesting to see what happens with it
I'm one of those that believes that
certainly that is a factor but I think
the main reason people aren't signing
them because they question where he is
both in terms of his abilities to play
quarterback in the NFL right now that
clearly denigrated over the last couple
years some but not as well and the fact
of just where where's football is a
priority for you and if it's not that's
okay too
if these other things are a higher
priority for you that's great god love
you but but if I'm gonna bring you on my
football team I want to know where
football places and your priorities
Brian good to catch up with you again
thank you for joining us Brian Billick
NFL on Fox Continental Tire Coach's
Corner Continental Tire the official
tire of Major League Soccer and soccer
fans expect peak performance on the
pitch and also demand peak performance
on the street that's my
nano has built a tire for what you do
whether you're heading to the game or
you want to go off-roading best in class
but braking superb handling Continental
Tire proud supported the Dan Patrick
show visit Continental Tire dot-com for
more the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience